hell happens every day in the besieged
city of mariopol
emergency workers at this residential
block search for survivors
the mayor says more than 20 000 people
have been killed as russian forces used
conventional weapons to batter and
besiege this city
then overnight
a claim they may have resorted to
chemical agents too
ukrainian fighters released interviews
with a handful of people alleged to have
been affected
a soldier from ukraine's as of battalion
said his unit had no capacity to run
toxicology tests but he said whatever
had been fired had caused victims
briefly to pass out
what we have right now just the unusual
symptoms yeah of unknown substance yeah
and thank god the people were exposed to
these substances for not a very long
time in the uk a defense minister said
he couldn't confirm if a chemical weapon
had been deployed something britain is
urgently checking but he warned of the
consequences should such a red line be
crossed let's be clear if they are used
at all
then president putin should know that
all possible options are on the table in
terms of how the west might respond
but it's unclear what impact any western
threats have on the calculations of the
russian leader here out visiting a space
center with his bella russian ally
he repeated his baseless excuses for the
the clash with neo-nazi forces in
ukraine was unavoidable
they were choosing a time to attack
later developments demonstrated how
deeply it was embedded it's an obvious
fact this neo-nazism became a fact of
life of quite a big country close to us
the only fact of life in mariopol is
that it's being extinguished by russia's
war and it's an attack that looks set to
intensify as russian forces refocus
firepower on the south east
for the ukrainian defenders they'll
fight to win
die trying or end up captured do you
think you can survive this or are you
worried that you will die
are you willing to die
am i sure that i will survive
i guess not i'm not sure will i survive
second one do i
fear death no do i will that no i will
not die i will not die enjoy fight
a british volunteer fighting with them
has had to surrender to the russians
28 year old aiden aslan who goes by the
name johnny is pictured on the right
russia-backed separatists fighting in
the east denied using chemical weapons
in mariopol
but western officials fear the longer
this war goes on the greater the risk
they will be debrahing sky news keeve